bonjour bienvenue dans une nouvelle
émission spéciale consacrée aux
élections départementales et nous nous
intéressons aujourd'hui aux enjeux dans
le département de l'orne émission
également que nous vous proposons en
collaboration avec le journal ouest
france et la radio france bleu
basse-normandie à mes côtés justement
francis gauguin rédacteur en chef de
france bleu bonjour francis bonjour
franck bonjour à tous et patrick brionne
responsable du bureau ou ouest-france
d'alençon bonjour patrick jours alors je
rappelle que ces élections
départementales auront lieu les 22 et 29
mars prochain que vous élirez des
binômes un homme et une femme pour une
durée de six ans et que les cantons ont
été redécoupée pour permettre à un
meilleur équilibre entre la ville et la
campagne pour débattre dans un instant
on accueille sur ce plateau jérôme nury
pour l'ump
bonjour bonjour vous êtes maire de
tinchebray et vice président du conseil
général frédéric léveillé pour le parti
socialiste
bonjour vous êtes conseiller général et
maire adjoint d'argentan raymond
herbreteau vous êtes candidat pour le
front national
bonjour christine roimier candidate est
conseillère municipale d'alençon vous
porter les couleurs de lui d yvon jour
dont jour et jean chatelais vous êtes
candidat pour le front de gauche et
conseiller régional un jour
chaunu le dessinateur chaunu nous
accompagnent bon jour venu bonjour
franck la semaine dernière nous étions
dans la manche n'est ce pas et il y
avait un grand absent mais c'est normal
il partait en retraite a salué jean
françois le grand
là il ya un grand absent aujourd'hui
c'est alain lambert alors je vous
rassure il est devant sa télé va vous
regarder franck et francis et vous tous
à il préfère garder son fauteuil vous
parce que je pense qu'il n'a pas nommé
monsieur nourrissant successeur donc il
est devant sa télé et on le salue alain
si tu nous regardes bonjour oui emmanuel
là il manque effectivement un invité à
savoir le président sortant alain
lambert
qui était à la tête du département
depuis 2007 il est à l'uni il a annoncé
qu'il briguait sa succession nous
l'avons invité il a décliné la
proposition et s'en est expliqué dans un
communiqué envoyé par son directeur de
cabinet en début de semaine on le
découvre je le lis vous avez choisi pour
votre émission un format que je
comprends parfaitement auquel je
souscris celui de donner la parole aux
formations politiques n'exerçant aucune
fonction dans un party vous comprendrez
que je ne me sente pas légitime pour
participer au débat et il ajoute je vous
confirme que je me situe en opposition
frontale avec ceux qui préconise la
suppression des départements plus ou
moins ouvertement assumée par le
gouvernement alors qu'il s'agit pour
être franc termine-t-il de la seule
question majeurs posés par ces élections
voilà fin de citation
quels sont les enjeux dans le
département de l'orne
on en arrive au débat justement sur ce
qui intéresse les électeurs l'orne est
un département où le front national lors
des dernières élections européennes l'an
passé a dépassé la barre des 30 % le fn
qui en l'espace de six ans a multiplié
son score par 3 sur ces élections
européennes et il était de 9% en 2009
le fn qui si l'on en croit les sondages
serait en tête du premier tour de ces
départementale on va voir un dernier
sondage qui est paru cette semaine un
sondage csa/le le fn arrive en tête donc
avec 29% devant l'ump 25 % le ps en 3e
position 21 % ensuite viennent le front
de gauche lui dit et europe écologie
aucune de ces formations politiques ne
dépasse la barre des 6%
est ce que le front national va
confirmer son enracinement dans l'orne
c'est la première question que l'on se
pose dans ce débat je vais adresser à
jérôme nury d'abord est ce que ces
chiffres que l'on vient de donner ce ne
sont que des sondages mais vous inquiète
d'abord moi je crois monsieur banier que
vous comme beaucoup de journalistes
d'être en train de vous tromper
d'élection
c'est dire qu'il est en train de
comparer des carottes et des choux pour
faire une mauvaise soupe journalistique
parce que là nous sommes bien des
élections départementales qui ne sont
pas des élections de politique
politicienne où les enjeux sont des
enjeux locaux où il s'agit de choisir
des candidats que les gens connaissent
qui sont implantées sur le territoire
avec un projet un projet départemental
et donc que de nous montrer des sondages
sur la france entière donc avec des
villes où on le sait très bien les
conseils généraux sont moins puissants
beaucoup moins d'action générale de la
santé rappelle également les quelques
instants le score du front national qui
est arrivé en tête des dernières
élections de référence à savoir les
européennes des élections européennes
nous sommes sur des élections qui sont
très politique avec des listes à la
proportionnelle
nous les partis politiques nous en
voyons jamais trop les plus
charismatiques de nos élus comme tête de
liste donc on peut pas dire que ça
pousse les électeurs à aller voter
donc nous sommes sur des élections bien
différente là nous sommes sur des
élections où la personnalité des
candidats va compter et où la proximité
va compter francis goya de france le
géant meneur est votre principal
adversaire à l'ump
dans l'orne pour ces cantonales ce sera
le front national on se sera la gauche à
monsieur moi je n'ai pas d'adversaire
paulienne pays je n'ai que des gens qui
sont contre la majorité départementale
contre l'action de canal v et vous
durant six ans qui craignez-vous le plus
la gomme et aujourd'hui nationale
aujourd'hui ce que je crains ce que je
crains c'est l'abstention je crains que
mes concitoyens étaient complètement
déboussolés par le charcutage que le
parti socialiste a fait sur les sur les
cantons par également ce mode de scrutin
qui est quand même un peu alambiqué
c'est ça que je craigne ballon pour
essayer de répartir de manière équitable
c'est la règle le temps de parole avec
ses cinq candidats je m'adresser à
rémois herbreteau puisqu'il était
question de vous jérôme nury dit ça
n'est pas une élection nationale ça
n'est pas un scrutin national
on va élire des représentants au conseil
départemental
vous représentez le front national
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez alors
effectivement il ya des enjeux locaux
mais je crois que tous les français
surtout les électeurs ont compris que
les enjeux locaux sont dépendants de la
politique nationale voire internationale
et que c'est difficile de dents dans
l'acte en une structure que nous
organise dans les réformes de territoire
ou à faire disparaître les communes les
départements au profit pour fait
souffler le front national lui et sa
triptyque c'est défendre les communes
défendent le département et un états
nations souverains et indépendants
voilà la question c'est de savoir la
question c'est de savoir si on les
défend la chaussure et savoir ce qu'est
le projet politique on a lesquels
rennais m'a demandé de retirer la
situation se baigner je crois que c'est
de laisser germer des gens se sentant
trahis alors que les parties
la dictature c'est pas de forcer les
gens à part les cds empêcher de parler
c'est ce que chanteront de se dire voilà
ou là ou là ou là c'est de permettre à
exprimer la parole mais donner je
voudrais calmer terminer mes propos
voilà alors que vu les partis politiques
si vous voulez occurrence je dirais même
pas de verser du concurrent e son parti
partisan de la triptyque région enfin
grande grande intercommunalité très très
grande région et l'europe donc déjà on
est dans une situation complètement
différente
alors bien entendu c'est cette politique
là qui fera qu' on pourra développer le
département en fonction des compétences
pour qu'on n'ait pas encore et en
fonction des budgets et des orientations
donc les enjeux locaux bien sûr qu'ils
sont importants mais ils sont tout à
fait tributaire de des enjeux que le
site est alors on va laisser là on va en
parler
christine roimier
qui représente lui dit jérôme nury dit
ça n'est pas une élection nationale est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui c'est
une campagne si ce n'est pas une
élection nationale
est ce que c'est une campagne pour ou
contre le front national d'euros de
marque hier dans journal ouest france et
par une tribune extrêmement
enrichissante sur le poids du front
national en fait tu envoies le prends le
front national et à des étiages constant
depuis des années des années
le problème c'est l'abstention c'est
alors donc effectivement sur une
élection européenne à très faible taux
de participation
le taux est élevé je crois qu'il faut
cesser de brandir des chiffons rouges
nous sommes effectivement sur une
élection locale avec des candidats qui
sont connus de leurs concitoyens et qui
seront appréciées sur leurs projets bien
entendu ou pour les sortantes sur ce
qu'ils ont fait aux cours dsk il n'y a
pas un risque que ces formules justement
de voir le front national même si vous
revendiquez que cette élection est une
élection locale qu'il faut s'intéresser
à l'avenir des départements sk par un
risque au regard des différentes études
qu'il faut publier de voir le front
national au square du 22 mars en tête de
ces élections
je peux vous dire que nous faisons tout
pour que justement ce ne soit pas le cas
mobilisation mobilisation mobilisation
c'est ce que tous les partis
républicains font aller voter jean
chatelais pour le front de gauche oui
effectivement le problème de
l'abstention est un problème extrêmement
important c'est lui effectivement qui
montrera un front national en othe
sondages mais ce sont des sondages
l'abstention pour nous front de gauche
elle est à combattre notamment parmi les
gens de gauche qui ne vont pas voter
parce qu'ils sont déçus de cette
politique nationale et qu'on le veuille
ou non ces élections cantonales
départemental comme on le veut encore
sont quand même porté par des dimensions
nationales notamment les politiques
d'austérité qui sont menées et cela je
ne suis pas d'accord avec monsieur nury
je pense que l'orne a enfin un
équilibrage de ces cantons de la parole
afin d' avec les vanniers pour le parti
socialiste
je crois d'abord que ces élections elles
sont là pour répondre aux
jeux et aux besoins des citoyens parce
que faudrait quand même arrêter de
gloser sur les réflexions parisiano
parisienne sur le front national moi ce
que je vois c'est le terrain et le
terrain c'est quoi c'est comment est-ce
qu'on répond aux gens sur des dossiers
de prestation compensatoire du handicap
comment est-ce qu'on répond aux gens sur
des dossiers d'appât comment est-ce
qu'on répond aux gens sur des sujets
liés à du rsa ça c'est des vrais sujets
et puis ça évite de vos dents devoir de
lire ce que j'ai lu dans ouest france il
ya peu de temps que par exemple des
idées du front national demande de
supprimer une subvention ou une aide un
truc a déjà été supprimés depuis trois
ans ce qui prouve qu'ils connaissent pas
les sujets des dossiers alors aller mais
compétent justement et des propositions
vous faites pour pour ce département de
l'ordre question de francis de rien mais
j'ai juste une question à monsieur
herbreteau le front national pour le
front national le front national
s'autoproclame souvent porte parole de
la ruralité
on est dans un département rural lormes
or quand on examine les candidatures sur
l'ensemble de la france c'est ce qu'a
fait l'institut harris
récemment on s'aperçoit que vous n'avez
qu'un % de candidats issus du milieu
agricole au front national
alors est-ce que comment vous expliquer
cela quelle est la difficulté vous avez
des difficultés pour être représentatif
en milieu rural là où pourtant vous
faites des voix disant eh bien ça lui
agrée ou europe écologie à l'aller ils
représentent si vous voulez cela si vous
voulez on peut très bien comprendre que
l'image du front national n'est pas
encore très très positif au beaucoup de
gens et c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui
aimeraient participer qui sont peut-être
un peu frileux parce que oui vous êtes
du front national c'est celle où là donc
en fait la vraie question c'est des
projets que l'on porte qui sont
intéressants puisque les personnes c'est
d'engranger les candidats partout mais
oui alors il faut dire partout on
recouvre quand même 95% des du
territoire national dans les cantons qui
représente une possibilité de 90 + 18 %
de la population de pouvoir voter front
national voilà est en fait nous on se
présente sans se cacher derrière des
faux logo ou autre chose tout le nom
candidats son front national rbm
alors on va faire un peu de pédagogie et
refermer cette page
politique sur ces enjeux pour rappeler
que les élections départementales donc
ont lieu effectivement premier tour le
22 mars second tour le 29 mars que vous
devez lire donc des binômes et que dans
l'orne ça va considérablement changer
je m'excuse de le dire mais l'image de
l'assemblée il n'y a pour l'instant que
4 femmes sur 40 qui sont conseillers
généraux demain ça sera du 50 50
votre commentaire qu'est ce qui nous
ramène là jérôme bats pas m'en vouloir
mais je trouve que c'est plutôt bien
donc je suis content voilà effectivement
je pense que ça nous aurait plus que les
choses se fassent plus naturellement
mais je crois quand même façon lorsque
la loi a imposé des listes dites de
chabada pour les élections municipales
ça a permis à un certain nombre de
femmes de devenir conseillère municipale
aujourd'hui ce vivier de femmes devenue
conseillère municipale vont pouvoir
solliciter les suffrages plus facilement
que par le passé voilà je crois qu'il
faut encore mentionner les choses même
si on regrette on aurait préféré
autrement mais les parents d'élèves
pardon pour l'instant je crois non c'est
le conse c'est pas des questions de
volonté délibérée
c'étaient les choses étaient comme ça
les hommes exerçaient des
responsabilités publiques
et puis les femmes aux seins pas tandis
que maintenant et l aller les chercher l
réseau et elle s'y vautrer dans les
riches précédent et puis oui oui tout à
fait donc quand même pas le seul
département à avoir un peu de femmes
dans l'assemblée car le passé par groupe
axa oui mais regardez d'autres
départements notamment des départements
ruraux
vous avez beaucoup d'élus notamment des
mères qui étaient des mères masculin les
assemblées départementales étaient
plutôt quand même avec des hommes
composée d'hommes mais moi ce que je
veux dire aussi c'est que ça c'est le
point positif c'est de dire aujourd'hui
la moitié de femmes dans sa table et
d'un parc départemental c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour tout le monde et on le
voit bien où dans un de nos assemblées
municipales c'est bien de travailler
aussi avec les femmes mais où même quand
même et qui est soulignée à chaque fois
c'est que nous allons avoir plus d'élues
sur les départements à l'heure où on
nous dit qu'il faut faire des économies
où il faut essayer captivité voilà on
serre la ceinture en mai 40 2 nuls alors
qu'à bord il y en avait 40
alors on va les séparer tout le monde a
essayé de le faire avancer les missions
rapidement puisque chacun va faire la
lumière sur la parité qui met
obligatoires dont les conseils
départementaux
c'est un film sur les événements pour le
parti socialiste jean retraité et sur ce
point la vingtaine avait noté une femme
à l'assemblée départementale
je pense que ça va changer aussi la
teneur des débats
et quand on sait les compétences du
département sur la petite enfance sur
les transports scolaires sur les
collèges à ce qu'ils vont ils rester sur
un certain nombre d'autres sujets qui
sont des sujets qui intéressent
directement les femmes sur l'aide
sociale à l'enfance qu'une compétence
unique des départements eh bien je pense
qu'on aura des débats qui seront plus
intéressante plus pragmatique sans doute
plus utile - fantômes peut-être que
selon ce qu'on disait moi pas forcément
avaient dit leur dernier mot si le
général un débat sur l'action sociale
nous l'avons vu
malheureusement nous avons été trois
jean chatelais pour le front de gauche
et raymond herbes hautes eaux à qui on
va faire avancer l émission parce qu'on
a évoqué mais monsieur vigneault sacré
c'est très très bien de soulever cette
question à la veille du 8 mars qui quand
même une journée de la femme
mais il n'empêche que l'on soit fan club
pour nous l'important au front de gauche
et le parti communiste c'est les idées
politiques bien évidemment et c'est ce
débat
sera-t-il plus serein l'essentiel ce qui
est un débat sur le fond politique entre
mais ça sera voilà de toute rationalité
une obligation mais ça va changer
effectivement l'image des conseils
départementaux pas seulement dans l'orne
à dans la manche on en parlait la
semaine dernière ça sera également le
cas et dans le calvados aussi à un
chiffre de 50 50
rémois herbreteau juste sur cette
question rappelle rapidement voulu
réagir oui c'est ça je voulais dire
nationale on est contre la
discrimination positive
déjà dans la constitution à l'inscrit
toute différence de sexe de couleurs et
ses 2 et sont interdits voilà donc c'est
pas du tout pour les comptes auprès des
femmes se présentent bien au contraire
le chef de parti c'est une femme malade
moynier a fait comme une carrière
intéressante la ville d'alençon c'était
une femme
donc voilà
même s'il y avait plus de femmes qu'il
était candidate je vois pas
d'inconvénient mais pousser les gens à
se présenter je trouve ça quand même un
sacré paradoxe de discrimination
positive au front national
chacun sait que j'ai dans chacun chez
soi c'est à chacun peut voir je peux
dire à peut avoir sa chance à se
présenter à se motiver
mais c'est pas du tout le fait d'être
contre les candidates femmes si elles
étaient plus nombreuses va ce serait
très bien également
elle avait pas de discrimination
positive aux questions de patrick brion
une vraie difficulté justement pour
trouver des binômes féminin vous front
national non ça c'est fait quand même
assez facilement et il a fallu aussi
peut-être les motiver parce que bon le
cadre de la loi il est assis donc ça
nécessite aussi un pédagogique est en
charge mais je crois que sur le
territoire français on a eu quand même
des deux femmes très brillante dans tous
les domaines même en politique sans pour
cela qu'on les oblige à faire les choses
l'association lors l'orne est un
département rural qui compte
on le disait au début de cette émission
297 mille habitants ce sera le plus
petit des cinq départements qui
constitueront la grande normandie en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2016
comment comptez vous si vous êtes élu
demain aux départements au conseil
départemental défendre les atouts de
l'orne en sachant qu'à côté vous aurez
le calvados 680 mille habitants ou
encore la seine-maritime un million deux
cent mille habitants quatre fois plus
que dans votre département
comment on défend l'orne demain
justement tu aurais c'est à christine
roimier vous savez nous avons toujours
été le plus petit département de la
région donc ça va pas beaucoup nous
changer
et donc quand on est le plus petit faut
être plus malins et je crois que grâce à
la qualité des projets nous voulons
porter pour ce département rural qui a
plein d'avenir qui qui doit avoir
confiance en lui dans ses actes ou et
bien nous saurons à l'intérieur de la
région à 5
à l'intérieur de cette collégialité des
cinq départements être ce qui apporte
quelque chose au projet des cinq
départements
lakers sa spécificité mais en même temps
qu'ils sauront faire une majorité qui
seront emportés un arbitrage parce que
justement c'est ça l'intérêt d'être le
risque en nombre le plus petit d'être
noyé dans cette grande normandie studio
est présent parce qu'en championnat fait
baiser régional général pardon pour lui
nous sommes très préoccupés par ces
questions et féminisme ans le problème
de l'orne
c'est le problème des cinq départements
où effectivement ces grandes régions
normandes va établir des rapports très
démocratique et très respectueux mais
avec une ambiguïté puisque nous ne
connaissons pas les compétences tout de
suite et ce qui a quand même mené cette
nouvelle loi cette nouvelle organisation
c'est quand même la compétitivité entre
les territoires occurrence et
compétitivité c'est pardon pour lormes
et c'est pour ça que nous pensons nous
qu'il faut réformer et à voir dans
l'ensemble de cette normandie
effectivement des rapports démocratique
très intense comme ils ont pu être faits
notamment avait envers l'ordre dans
cette basse normandie et surtout veiller
à ce que chacun soit bien effectuer un
mur et c'est quoi les atouts de leur
nommer un contexte et moi je rende leurs
ventes faut pas voir là une dent l'on
dit on va voir la grande normandie comme
une menace
il faut le voir comme une opportunité il
faut le voir pour l'homme comme étant le
moyen de se faire entendre de faire une
alliance avec les autres territoires
ruraux pour poser face on le sait à des
métropoles à des ensembles urbains qui
on voit en avoir la tentation de prendre
la main qui vont avoir la tentation de
faire porter des projets exclusivement
par exemple sur ces grandes métropoles
sur ces grandes capitales c'est à nous
d'être malade d'être plus fort c'est
faire ce que disait christine roy mais
c'est à dire ces lycées * 6e ils se
gavent de potion magique pour pouvoir
contre les soldats romains qui sont
beaucoup plus nombreux se battre et bien
alors ça va être ça va être avec des oui
mais regardez astérix fini par
l'emporter
frédéric léveillé mon parti social et
sur ce sujet là moi je pense que c'est
pas seulement la taille qui compte c'est
aussi la stratégie qu'on y met et moi je
fais confiance aux ornaise et aux ornais
et à leur capacité d'innovation
l'innovation dans l'économie innovation
dans l'agriculture
exemple écoutez j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de citer sur ce plateau mais j'y reviens
parce que c'est important quand on a une
entreprise argentanais d'écouté c'est
sur mon canton genre profil qui
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle mf tech et qui
a fabriqué le roman qui construit et qui
fabrique au venezuela les bouteilles de
gaz
eh bien écoutez si ça c'est pas
d'innovation argentan domaines de
l'appellation c'est comme ça c'est une
vraie stratégie il ne restera que j'ai
d'innovation une vraie volonté de
pouvoir porter des territoires et c'est
valable aussi dans l'artisanat c'est
valable aussi dans le commerce c'est
valable aussi dans des sujets qui sont
des sujets d'avenir tels que par exemple
la transition énergétique
il faut qu'on y traite en vidéo
consommation de l'homme dans l'orne perd
des emplois et de l'orne percée jeunes
alors si la normandie
alors est ce à quoi ressemblera le
département de l'orne dans les années
qui viennent c'est une question qu'on
peut se poser vraiment un bateau pour le
fonds national boullier oui simplement
sur la place de langues dans la grande
normandie puis ces services je voulais
terminer peut-être moins m'exprimer les
fautes et les îles sont entendus bon
j'ai pas tout à fait la même vision dans
le sens où je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres qui vont bien éclairer la
situation de l'ordre notre densité home
km² ses 48 habitants la france la
moyenne de ses 114
donc ça veut dire on est déjà un
département sous comment je dois dire
sous habité et qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire attendez je dirais alors page que
je veux dire c'est le taux de natalité
il à 10% que la moyenne nationale et ou
60 le taux de mortalité est de 11 60 et
le niveau national 8,70 géographie oui
mais c'est aussi ça vous ennuie un jour
a fait une différence entre l'histoire
et des histoires
alors donc je termine vraiment trop ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'on est dans
une situation on est dans une situation
je pas terminée merci donc un autre
chiffre
les gens ne terminera après les chiffres
l'orne et le 68e
département dans le classement pour le
produit intérieur brut par habitant à
1860 s'il 109
sachant que les chiffres monsieur
grandes villes comme paris c'est 67000
cet aveu dire pratiquement trois fois et
demie plus bon ce qui veut dire ces
examens il ya une sacrée problématique
dans l'urne
j'arrive à l'est sont pénalisés qui va
être pénalisé
je sais bien que c'est pas comparer deux
départements comparables à mais nous
compare les ouïes reconnaissez que quand
même fort national a le mérite de vous
réveiller bon ceci dit c'est une
supposition aux éléments moigno s'il
vous plaît c'est un débat autour des
élections ont terminé en vendée on passe
à autre chose
il ya une grande politique européenne
qui fait avec l'apa qui va détruire les
emplois agricoles le marché
transatlantique qui doit inonder le
marché français dont corner aussi pour
nos éleveurs ça va être une catastrophe
à ce niveau la question de patrick brion
rush les gens des lois justes ans à
venir donc peut-être aux perspectives
justement qu'est ce que l'homme peut
faire valoir
l'échelle de cette grande normandie je
suis en moto alors ce qu'elle peut faire
valoir effectivement on peut déjà
regretté devant le maire du moule inex
ceci dit il ya des industries de
rejoindre il ya des industries quand
même qui marche bien sûr qu'il faut les
soutenir
mais ce que je veux dire il faut être
réaliste si on n'a pas une politique
nationale de réindustralisation si vous
voulez de l'autre pays
il n'aura pas de conséquence sur le
alors accès ressemblera le département
de l'orne dans les années qui viennent
et puis je vous demander simplement de
décider de respecter le temps de parole
ne pas faire des réponses trop longues
parce que je vais être obligée à la fin
de l'émission de laisser parler quelques
candidats deux ou trois candidats et les
autres ou et excuser leur temps de dante
d'antenne donc pour vous permettre
d'intervenir sur tous les sujets on va
essayer de faire des réponses assez
courte
à quoi ressemblera le département de
l'orne dans les années qui viennent si
l'on en croit l'insee d'ici 2032 le
nombre d'habitants ne devrait pas bouger
sur le tour de trois cent mille
habitants
l'homme qui néanmoins devrait voir une
augmentation importante du nombre de
personnes âgées de plus de 80 ans
un papy boom qui va réellement débuter
en 2017 c'est demain donc c'est un
problème que vous aurez à gérer
comment à la tête des conseils
départementaux
on prend en charge cette population
vieillissante jérôme nury pour l'ump
vous savez que là nous sommes en plein
dans les compétences du département avec
justement l'accompagnement des séniors
l'orne est déjà très mobilisés depuis
plusieurs années pour que nos maisons de
retraite soit agrandi pour que nous
puissions également avoir plus de place
et d'ailleurs nous sommes un des
départements les plus dotés les mieux
dotés en nombre de place pour nos
anciens dans nos maisons de retraite que
l'on retrouve d'ailleurs disséminés sur
tout le territoire et puis à toute la
politique d'acompte 76 maisons de
retraite
oui j'y voyais avec avec un nombre
presque 45 sans perturber de temps je
vais vous dire la statistique c'est nous
avons 130 places pour 1000 habitants qui
ont plus de 75 ans alors qu'en france
c'est 90 donc nous sommes en quelque
sorte surdotées sur le nombre de places
en maisons de retraite
donc ce qui veut dire aussi qu'il faut
cet accompagnement le faire à la fois
d'établissement mais le faire à domicile
et nous avons des partenaires avec l'una
et admr et nous servons la page me
rappeler a eu 1500 aux relances rappelle
là et à des meilleurs simplement pour
ceux qui ce sont des associations
locales qui s'occupe de nos anciens qui
les accompagne dans leur vie quotidienne
d'accord frédéric léveillé pour le parti
socialise écoutez je pense que le
constat est juste c'est à dire que nous
sommes bien noté statistiquement sauf
que nous connaissons tous sur nos
cantons des situations réelles concrète
de gens qui sont aujourd'hui en attente
de pouvoir rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle
les ehpad les établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes et qui sont aujourd'hui par
exemple à devoir attendre pour être par
exemple en cellule alzheimer on en a
tous
donc c'est vrai que statistiquement on
est au dessus sauf que comme nous avons
plus de personnes âgées
nous devons aussi prendre ce débat à
bras le corps nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de le demander d'ailleurs
dans le cadre de l'assemblée
départementale pour qu'on ait un vrai
débat une vraie discussion un vrai sujet
une vraie perspective là dessus parce
que il y a
nous faisons sur n'a pas aujourd'hui et
c'est important d'établissements l'état
pour les plains pas pour les personnes
mais il ya aussi une perspective à fixer
et nous devons aller au-delà et
d'ailleurs y compris au delà de la
situation de la politique de monsieur
nationale une super nier une obligation
il vient de la présence au générique
aujourd'hui nous avons des listes
d'attentes effectivement dans nos
maisons de retraite quel est le problème
c'est que dès qu'on veut ouvrir des
places donc des lits supplémentaires
dans les maisons de retraite
il faut avoir si vous voulez la double
autorisation à la fois du département
est à la fois de l'état et aujourd'hui
nous attendons de la part de la grèce et
de la part de l'état que le plan
alzheimer se met en place et puissent
venir co financé ses suiveurs du corps
enseignant sous sarko des maisons de
retraite et nous attendons toujours
monsieur léveillé comment est-ce qu'on
finance l'a pas génial attendu pendant
cinq ans de sarkozy et qu'on attende oui
monsieur hollande depuis trois ans alors
une population qui vieillit en l'orne
wassim qu' il y aura trente mille orné
kir ont dépassé l'âge de 80 ans en 2002
32 si l'on s'en réfère à ces chiffres de
l'insee jean chatelais que dites vous
est-ce qu'il faut construire de
nouvelles maisons de retraite
alors si vous êtes demain à la table du
département est ce que c'est une de vos
premières décisions
non je crois pas qu'il faille ouvrir
d'autres ehpad
avec une particularité dans land commun
qui n'est pas que dans l'ordre c'est que
vous savez que moi que les moyennes des
retraites dans la région flérienne par
exemple ses 800 euros et le premier est
pas tu commences à 1600 donc on a quand
même une difficulté importante
par contre la politique us confesse que
ces difficultés
que proposez vous justement il ya
d'autres choses sur lequel le
département n'est est en recul
demain il ya une manifestation
importante de l'unasur le pont qui
rejoint les deux normandie c'est une
manifestation des associations à qui
s'occupe justement des aides à domicile
et en matière d'aidé à domicile
il faut reconnaître c'est le budget du
département et qu'on n'est pas à la
hauteur des besoins
avant de mettre les gens en ehpad à 80
ans il ya toute une disponibilité des
d'actions à mettre en oeuvre pour que
les gens puissent vivre le plus
longtemps chez eux et là on est vraiment
par exemple comme quoi très bien quand
il ya notamment sur les taux horaires
des aides à domicile le département a
fait un recul il ya un an deux ans je
sais plus exactement
sur les prises de participation qui sont
faites pour les personnes résultat on a
eu des pertes d'emplois dans ces
associations
ce sont des emplois en un an - en le
département 65 du projet du budget de 65
60 % du budget en matière sociale est
très peu d'emplois sociaux et jeu
puisque l'on parle des maisons de
retraite je rappelle qu'elles sont sous
dotées sous doté en personnel notamment
en nettoyant qui sont restés du
département tueur de francis gauguin de
france vite si on veut maintenir à
domicile les personnes âgées il faut
aussi que dans ce département il y ait
des médecins aujourd'hui la
désertification médicale et on la
connaît dans ce département c'est 200
médecins c'est quoi l'âge moyen du
médecin aujourd'hui ses 58 ans dans
l'orne et et et on dit qu'en 2018 lors
n'aura perdu la moitié de ses médecins
alors là encore c'est à béthune
libérales mais que peut faire le
département comme l'orne jean murith moi
ce que je veux rapplique c'est que nous
sommes là sur une politique et que
durant de nombreuses années notamment
sous les gouvernements jospin
on s'est amusé à baisser le numerus
clausus croyants qui lui aurait
finalement moins des déficits sur la
sécurité sociale ça a été faut donc ce
que l'on a fait dès qu'on ne revient au
pouvoir remonter le numerus clausus pour
former le plus de médecins par an nous
n'avons jamais eu autant de médecins en
france qu aujourd'hui le seul problème
c'est qu'ils sont mal réparties donc
c'était non pas dans l'ordre maintenant
en tout cas collectivités locales
d'essayer de faire face parce que l'état
on le voit bien ne s'occupe pas beaucoup
de cela qu'est ce que vous faites pour
nous et c'est sincère
l'appartement fait plusieurs choses le
département met en place des pôles de
santé libéraux ambulatoire qui permet de
réunir les professionnels en un seul
lieu pour pouvoir exercer de manière
collégiale la médecine mais également
réunir des kinés réunir tous ces profils
mais sans que ça suffit non ménagers pas
nous sommes aussi engagés dans une
opération de séduction de ses étudiants
par exemple canet pour les accueillir
notamment quand ils font de leur star à
l'aise en désintox accueillir balade
dans l'orne pour qu'ils découvrent notre
département qui découvrent la qualité de
vie la fonction encore les attendait
pour faire un médecin il faut huit à dix
ans donc naturellement les efforts que
l'on fait aujourd'hui vont porter que
d'ici quelques années
donc voilà tous ces efforts là doivent
payer et puis il faut aussi que l'état
joue son rôle je crois alors le
département de l'orne et est un
département rural
le disais on parler de l'accueil de ces
médecins et la question du maintien
également des habitants il ya un grand
nombre de très petites communes dans le
département 55 villages contre moins
d'une centaine d'habitants par exemple
comment maintenir une vie dans les
campagnes il ya souvent plus de commerce
plus de services plus d'écoles et
pourtant paradoxalement on s'aperçoit
qu'il y ait un retour des populations
dans ces villages et dans le milieu
rural
57 % des habitants de l'ordre vivent en
milieu rural
comment leur permet de vivre comme à la
ville ou presque avec des services des
commerces des écoles raymond arbres trop
et royaux pour le front national menacé
ça donc brièvement je peux que souscrire
en globalement ce qui était dire ce qui
concerne d'effectivement l'aide aux
personnes âgées le handicap bien entendu
la libération du numerus clausus aussi
ce qui est une bonne chose
après je pense que quand même on
pourrait aussi développer la domotique
chez les gens pour les retenir plus
longtemps chez eux ce serait quand même
nous on en a parlé aux pme répondre ce
sujet puis l'appareil mais il faut qu'on
avance
juste un mot est par contre quelque
chose si canal oublier c'est le handicap
pour 10,2 scolaire et sur la question
pour faire avancer le débat et évoqué un
certain nombre de sujets cette
problématique du maintien des activités
en milieu rural je le disais 55 communes
d'une centaine d'habitants ont même
moins de 200 habitants vraiment à
bretons que proposez vous comment
fait-on est ce que si vous êtes élu
demain conseiller départemental ou à la
tête de ce département de l'orne
vous prenez une décision problématique
pour maintenir une vie dans les
campagnes et sur la vie dans les corps
pour laquelle quelles décisions alors ça
ça va dépendre aussi du budget qu'on va
avoir les orientations les pertes
compétences on peut pas si vous voulez
c'est toujours facile en période
électorale
l'affiché un catalogue de promesses
qu'on a produit depuis 20-30 ans il fait
une fois qu'on allait les rênes en main
mais on s'aperçoit qu'on peut pas faire
s'il faut pas faire ça donc je veux pas
trop entrer dans ce jeu là mais il est
bien certain que la paire des services
publics
on a connu de par la poste de par
l'administration et cetera ça fait
perdre de la vitalité dans les
départements et dans les commerces et
donc les gens à des vérifications
est ce que je vais vous le dire ça
dépendra aussi du budget au niveau
national selon comment les orientations
oui selon qu'on les entend les
orientations financières vont être
faites pour faire tous ces projets il
faut de l'argent frais payés pour parti
socialiste de trois choses lors l'enjeu
c'est de répondre aux besoins des
citoyens sur la nature moi je j'écume
comme tout le monde mon mon canton et
les communes rurales en particulier des
vraies problématiques qui se posent
aujourd'hui la problématique de la
mobilité
c'est une vraie problématique qui se
pose pour des gens qui n'ont pas le
permis de conduire et qui habite à la
campagne
comment on fait comment on trouve des
solutions à des solutions on peut les
trouver il faut d'abord se prendre un
peu en main et faire en sorte que l'on
puisse assurer par exemple du transport
à la demande sur les territoires pour
permettre aux gens de pouvoir se
déplacer à ce qu'on le départ parce que
ça peut que moi je l'aimé je rejoins sur
les dérives des beignets il a raison
c'est déjà en eure-et-loir qui est
d'accord avec le parti social il va nous
amener un peu le sujet c'est quelle
mascarade on est sur un territoire et on
travaille tous pour ce territoire là
dessus la raison il est vrai que le
département est le premier partenaire
des collectivités locales et donc des
intercommunalités et des communes qui
assurent ses services et service de
transport à la demande
ce sont souvent les intercommunalités
qui les gère accompagné par le
département nous sommes nous en train de
le faire atteindrait par exemple avec de
l'électro mobilité avec des voitures
électriques nous sommes accompagnés par
le conseil général nous sommes là sur
des actions novatrices qu'il faut
développer sur ce département pour
apporter toujours plus de services à la
population et la population rurale c'est
la même chose sur le commerce chinois
mais pour les éditions souvent alors on
a vu aspirations des habitants a
retrouvé les nénés campagne allait vivre
pas parce qu'une aussi il ya des
problèmes de coût des habitats c'est
plus cher dans les villes
même si on n'est pas sûr des métropoles
dans l'eure mais c'est plus cher de se
payer une maison en ville qu'à la
campagne christine roimier qu'est-ce
qu'on fait justement pour permettre aux
habitants de d'avoir pas les mêmes
chances mais presque en ville
moi je voulais saluer le travail
qu'avait fait jérôme nury sur le
numérique
je crois beaucoup que le numérique c'est
l'avenir des territoires ruraux
c'est ce qui répond aux attentes en
termes de services d'accès à
l'information
c'est ce qui peut résoudre répondre en
partie au maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées avec tous les
déploiements et c'est ça la voix de la
vitalité du monde rural
parce qu'effectivement les gens ont
envie de revenir dans des espaces où
l'habitat est moins chère complétée par
une politique de soutien à la rénovation
de l'habitat ancien dans les milieux
ruraux vraie politique très très définis
et très déterminé et puis là c'est
chaunu qui nous fait sourire tout à fait
numérique j'ai cassé ce noble métier
pendant 20 ans et je sais de quoi vous
parlez
le plan numérique
mais si on en a les moyens on l'accélère
toutes les technologies ont été une mise
en oeuvre pour y parvenir le transport à
la demande tous qu'il mobilité des
personnes et des informations
le numérique j'ai enterré oui je veux
remercier christine royer par rapport au
plan numérique orné effectivement qui
est tournée je le rappelle en priorité
vers les campagnes
c'est à dire vers les habitants qui dans
nos communes rurales n'ont pas encore
l'adsl c'est à dire les 17% d'ornay et
d'orner qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas d'adsl
et donc notre plan numérique vise à leur
amener ces technologies mais vise aussi
à les encourager à s'en servir
et quand on disait quels sont les
projets pour l'orne à l'horizon 2030 ou
demain c'est quoi c'est par exemple
d'encourager le télétravail nous avons
lancé un appel à projets pour développer
des télécentres qui s'appelle des
nomades center sur tous les départements
nous avons une petite douzaine
il faut poursuivre ces politiques là
pour encourager les personnes qui sont
en milieu urbain à revenir chez nous à
travailler chez nous mais leurs enfants
dans leurs impôts
je suis d'accord sur l'objectif n'est
pas que je changeais de ce que je
constate en d'accord ce que je constate
l'ensemble des l'ensemble des communes
que je visite on me dit que justement on
a un vrai problème
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut aussi être
mat de manière pragmatique répondent aux
besoins de montée en débit de haut débit
d'eau très haut débit parce que là non
plus il faut pas tromper les gens
on sait pertinemment que quand on
amènera le très haut débit les gens ont
boudé prendront pas forcément parce que
c'est pas le même prix ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut être pragmatique c'est
vrai cohérent et sérieux par rapport à
l'acte et matraqué font d'abord les
entreprises les organismes et pas
seulement les gens qui en effet il ya
des gens qui veulent travailler tes
travail tous les échantillons luis y
avoir tout simplement l'adsl pour
pouvoir s'en servir et pas seulement des
à titre professionnel alors les raisons
médicales
si le département de l'orne est sans
doute celui des trois départements bas
normands qui a le plus souffert en
matière d'emploi tout le monde se
souvient de la fermeture de moulinex qui
envoyait plus d'un millier de personnes
à alençon jusqu'en 2001 aujourd'hui le
plus gros employeurs du département
celle usine faurecia à flers 1450
personnes travaillent sur le site dans
la fabrication de sièges pour
l'automobile comment recréer de l'emploi
sachant que plus de 2000 emplois ont été
perdus dans le département lors des deux
dernières années
statistique insee là aussi notamment
dans l'industrie et dans le bâtiment
comment recréer de l'emploi je me
rendrai c'est à jean chatelais pour lé
front de gauche qui elle peut parler
écouter sur l'emploi dans l'emploi
industriel je le dénonce cette situation
au conseil régional depuis je suis au
conseil régional
effectivement les pertes d'emplois sont
nombreuses des mesures ont été prises
notamment une qui regardent les effets
c'est le fameux cice 19 9 millions ont
été versés pour les entreprises de
l'homme dont sont des entreprises de
langue pour créer des embauches et on
constate sur le terrain que les
embauches il n'y en a pas donc ce qui
veut bien dire que sur la politique
industrielle qui est menée au niveau
national il ya quand même un gros
problème
nous pensons donc effectivement cet
argent là doit être affectée mais qu'il
faut aussi aller chercher de l'argent
ailleurs
parce que cette question a été posée les
moyens que ce soit pour le numérique ou
les transports à condition que les
compétences restent au département parce
que ce n'est pas du tout dans les tuyaux
pour le moment
il faut de l'argent et des moyens
financiers en ses moyens financiers
alors jean quel type d'activité jean
chatelais ont fait venir dans l'orne ont
parlé des atouts du département il ya eu
quelques minutes les eaux reviennent à
tout le département peut développer pour
accueillir de nouvelles entreprises
les orner sur quel type d'activité les
orner sont une activité sont des gens
qui sont qualifiés au point de vue la
main d'oeuvre depuis des années et des
années on sur l'automobile il ya encore
de la place il manque 600 intérimaires
qui étaient avant chez faurecia qui
n'ont pas retrouvé d'emploi chez
faurecia l'industrie automobile sur
flers il n'y a pas de problème
la filière bois il n'y a pas de problème
non plus la transition énergétique et
tout ce qui est tourne autour de
l'écologie il y a plein d'emplois dans
l'orne
la méthanisation par exemple c'est un
développement d'emplois puisqu'on
parlait de plus que ses problèmes
d'énergie
il y à de multiples possibilités et
surtout surtout surtout ce qu'ils
recherchaient
et ce qui est nécessaire aux populations
parce qu'il faut répondre aux besoins
des populations
ce sont des emplois non pas que
d'ingénieurs mais des emplois moins
qualifiés et saluant de ces entreprises
ça existe alors quels atouts pour
développer l'emploi et faire en sorte
que le département ne perdent plus et
les emplois notamment industriels ne
s'éloignait des bassins que ça soit
alençon et argentan
ces derniers nous a dressé un portrait
de l'homme qui est en train de dépérir
moi je peux vous dire que tous les jours
c'est parce que l'on voit d'abord quand
vous dresser un portrait général ça veut
dire que devant une situation très
contrastée selon les territoires de
l'orne et si vous prenez une région que
je connais un peu plus qui est le bocage
ornais
nous ne perdons pas d'emploi il ya eu
une mutation de l'emploi qui s'était
reprise et au fur et à mesure mais nous
savons aussi qu'il s'agit maintenant de
jouer sur nos atouts nos atouts sais
quoi dans l'ordre c'est notamment
l'agriculture est derrière toute la
filière agroalimentaire nous avons des
projets en cours qui j'espère vont
aboutir qui vont permettre de créer
encore des emplois liés à
l'agroalimentaire et je peux vous dire
que pour l'orne s'est réellement pour le
21e siècle une vraie filière que l'on
peut encore développer et le département
et aux côtés de ces entrepreneurs là je
voyais tout le gentil socialiste de là
encore parlons concret il
koa j'entends une entreprise qui
travaille dans les glaces aujourd'hui
elle vient de récupérer une chaîne qui
est la chaîne qui fabrique les jumbo
alors je suis pas spécialiste mais en
tout cas c'est ce que m'ont dit les
salariés
et bien c'est tchétchène et tour notre
vite ça veut dire qu'ils ont là aussi il
ya une embauche qui a été faite derrière
ça veut dire qu'on a de la création on a
de la compétence des salariés on a on a
de l'efficacité des salariés savaient
quand ça a été posée par isco c'est une
entreprise belge
ils ont pensé que justement à argentan
ça marcherait pas et argentan ils ont
été dépassés
tous les compteurs possible parce qu'ils
ont montré leur efficacité salariés ces
emplois et pour les danses et enfants
issus de la filière agroalimentaire les
besoins d'alimentation du monde vont
exploser
il faut donc qu'on se situe sur ces
marchés internationaux et ensuite
qualitativement ils vont
considérablement se transformer on a
parlé du vieillissement de la population
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est conditionné
pour des familles en niveau
agroalimentaire va être de voir qu'on
dise être conditionnés pour départ
individuel et départ de personnes âgées
et donc à tout un travail de recherche
qui faire partir de ça qui ensuite d'un
débouché sur des fabrications et des
emplois nous sommes là dessus
complètement question de francis de rien
de france bleu hérault là-dessus toi je
vais vivre va continuer je veux pas vous
assommer de chiffres mais quand même 6
millions de chômeurs 9 million d'emplois
précaires 50% industrie qui est parti à
l'étranger
tant qu'on réglera pas ce problème n'y
aura pas de repas dans l'ordre naturel
on le sait que le monsieur moto
problème il n'y aura pas de retour s est
posé vous national a créé des emplois
non seulement il ya des choses des taux
le numérique c'est très bien de tout ce
qu'on a dit c'est un catalogue on peut
partager beaucoup de choses le problème
les gens il se plaît des effets et
chérissent les causes des problèmes
un moment il faut regarder en avant des
problèmes lors ne peut pas s'en sortir
tout seul comme n'importe quel
département
on a besoin d'un état stratège fort qui
sera capable lui de redéployer
l'industrie dans le sur le territoire
que soit l'heure où les autres de façon
à faire un partage à d'équilibrage des
chansons
si vous voulez heures foot dans le bocal
sortir de deux journées en six gains de
tous il ne garde france
est-ce que l'orne est encore trop
enclavé aujourd'hui alors je crois qu'on
est à 90 km d'autoroutes 30km de deux
fois deux voies 30 km2 deux fois de
suite sans même le patron d'agrial qui a
construit je prends un autre genre
conférant dans l'orne a existé au mois
d'octobre il disait enfin une route dans
l'orne il parlait de l'a88 est ce que là
encore il ya encore du retard à
rattraper est ce que il faut plus de
route aujourd'hui encore dans l'ombre
pour continuer à développer l'activité
économique
paramétrez kernel les routes pour l'ump
nous sommes au coeur du projet
départemental
parce que une partie de notre
investissement sur ces dernières années
a été consacrée comme les voies de
communication oui avec effectivement la
mise à deux fois deux voies notamment la
deux fois deux voies entre vire flair et
l'a88 donc l'a84 à 88,12 en avons besoin
nous avons également avec l'aide de la
région où il faut le souligner
effectivement nous travaillons également
sur la rn12 qui vient d'être inscrite
d'ailleurs au contrat de plan du on ne
peut que s'en réjouir
donc pour nous c'est essentiel mais
c'est aussi tout le réseau des voiries
départementales secondaires qui sont
essentiels si vous voulez pour venir ce
que vous aurez encore l'argent pour
financer ces infos mais attendez moi je
ne peux pas imaginer un instant que les
routes soient gérés c'est à dire ces
petites routes départementales qui a
dans chacune de nos communes rurales
soit je dirais géré depuis rouen ou deux
puis quoi encore ce n'est pas possible
là dessus j'espère que le législateur va
être un peu conscients d'avoir un moment
de lucidité pour que réellement ce soit
bien les conseils généraux
départementaux demain qui continue en gc
par des barreaux ce moment au parlement
est en bonne voie
je pense que c'est
fois ci puisque vous y faites japon par
contre je voulais insister sur un point
important parce que on a aussi et vous
l'avez rappelé des deux fois deux voies
un peu mais aussi des autoroutes
sauf que les autoroutes qui a deux
autoroutes le prix est démentiel les
gens ne la prennent pas l'autoroute et
pourquoi est ce que les traîneaux ciel
lorsque aujourd'hui ce sont des
entreprises privées qui la gère parce
que faut-il rappeler il faut il rappeler
qu'en 2008 les autoroutes ont été
bradées par nicolas sarkozy à 14
milliards et qu'aujourd'hui encore on se
sent le besoin de monsieur sarkozy
aujourd'hui il ya des situations par
exemple sur un territoire comme le mien
que je connais quand même
particulièrement il passe aujourd'hui
des camions sur une commune comme
aucagne tous les jours et tous les jours
en prend des risques
alors que si l'autoroute étaient moins
chers ils passeraient sur l'autoroute
qui on sait que sa haine de m messieurs
il faut que les jo il faut que l'état
remette de l'argent sur les routes mais
pas son admiration défendu mais c'est le
débat est le g1 peut ramener un peu de
sérénité avec une question de patrick
brion lors de la dernière session du
conseil général n'ait été déploré que
justement le précédent plan état région
avec plutôt profité au littoral ou à
l'agglomération caennaise est pas au
département de l'orne sur deux
programmes qui était plus ou moins prévu
sur la rn12
qu'est ce que vous faites demain pour
lui éviter qu'on soit confronté aux
mêmes écueils fait de même chez brioni
aujourd'hui mais on est là de la
négociation le conseil général a déjà
obtenu justement que c'est 40 millions
d'euros qu'il faut sur la rn12 puisse
être dégagée dans le cadre du contrat de
projet et chari je rappelle d'ailleurs
que c'est une discussion que j'ai eue il
ya quelques jours et que en l'occurrence
le président de région il ya mis tout
son pouvoir aussi oui mais c'était
important il a quand même fallu se
battre c'est pas pour ça que le centre
et on arrivera à la radiation
il faut quand même dire les choses aussi
les routes est pas non plus l'alpha et
l'oméga
si vous voulez du développement
économique d'un territoire et j'en veux
pour preuve le bocage qui représente 50%
du pib de l'orne
alors que finalement aujourd'hui nous
n'avons peu d'être deux fois deux voies
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de route
jusqu'à maintenant
alors il ya peu deux fois deux voies il
il ya peu de d owlient c'est quelque
chose qu'on a
servez dans le département on a compté
deux éoliennes je crois pour l'ensemble
du département
il ya beaucoup plus dans les deux
départements voisins la manche et le
calvados
est ce que demain il faudra accepter
davantage de projets éoliens le
président du conseil régional laurent
beauvais disait que l'homme devait
prendre sa part de responsabilité parce
que si demain vous êtes à la région jean
chatenet justement est-ce que 6 2 enfin
vous êtes à la tête du département pour
le coup de l'ordre vous autorisera qu'il
est facilement l'installation
d'éoliennes la difficulté qu'on a
notamment dans la partie département où
je suis c'est flers et que je vois bien
les éoliennes du calvados je vois bien
les éoliennes de la manche de chez moi
mais nous avons un projet sur la
communauté d'agglomération du pays de
flers de cinq éoliennes et nous n'avons
toujours pas de réponse de l'état alors
je sais bien que le département c'est un
peu compliqué nous avons deux parcs
naturels qui ont des paysages à protéger
d'autres zones qui sont aussi hors parc
naturel qui ont des paysages à protéger
mais l'éolien là aussi c'est pas
forcément l'alpha et l'oméga je parlais
de méthanisation tout à l'heure il ya
d'autres projets d'énergies nouvelles et
renouvelables autre que l'éolien refaire
tout le débat la question elle est très
claire très simple
c est ce que demain si vous êtes à la
tête de ce département de l'orne
vous dites oui aux éoliennes tout à fait
enfin dit oui alors raymond arbois tôt
au baseball front national oui alors si
vous voulez oui ou non attrapé on peut
répondre autrement c'est pas le jeu de 6
et les bouchons
non mais ça mérite un commentaire dans
le sens si on veut équiper la france en
éoliennes il faut 250 milles éolienne
pour se satisfaire des besoins de notre
pays si ou alors 5 milliards de mètre
carré
photovoltaïque qui correspondent à la
surface d'un département
non c'est pas le fait d'être contre les
énergies renouvelables il faudrait la
moitié des terres agricoles pour faire
du biocarburant voilà donc on n'est pas
à l'heure actuelle si vous voulez en
situation d'un développement et dorment
dans des parcs à me faire votre rue là
je dis non alors d'aujourd'hui je crois
qu'un des atouts principaux notre
département par les nouveaux emplois
c'est justement sa qualité de paysages
et les parcs naturels les pannes le
patrimoine un gisement d'emplois nous
avons des gisements d'emploi extrêmement
fort dans tous ses métiers de services
liés au tourisme lié à la santé liés aux
longs séjours etc et donc faisant
attention de ne pas le compromettre
pour le divan une efficacité dans le
domaine du renouvellement énergétique et
de la diversification énergétique est
pas complètement débattront de la par
contre dans le mélange éthique allons
vers la méthanisation qui correspond à
la à l'économie notre territoire très
largement agricole et n'allons pas d
affaiblir une filière potentiel très
puissante avec des politiques dont le
résultat sera une efficience moyens de
charges sur ce sujet là sur ce sujet dès
la transition énergétique très important
d'abord d'avoir des vrais débats ce
citoyen avec les gens parce qu'on
n'impose pas on réfléchit et on
travaille ensemble et on met des
perspectives
et puis surtout la diversification
énergétique ce sera peut être les
éoliennes ça peut être la méthanisation
ça peut être la faute aux tailles
ça peut être le bois le département de
l'ariège département très boisé il faut
qu'on ira en vironnement préservé avec
une décharge elles celle de gde français
gde il ya eu celle des bandes de gosses
aussi je le rappelle une s'endort
glissement bénéficiaires technique
alors si oui le globalement moi ce que
je regrette sur le plan politique c'est
que en fait le conseil général les
frappes et la compétence des ordures
ménagères de façon à mettre un petit peu
d'ordre si vous voulez dans la gestion
des déchets je ne sont pas des ordures
ménagères
oui les méchants industriels c'est du
r&b a produit une première automobile et
ses carrés et donc si vous voulez là
matic ça laisse la porte ouverte à des
industriels qui n'ont que faire de
certaines composantes par rapport à
l'environnement par pour la situation
est donc effectivement on se retrouve
dans des situations conflictuelles ou si
vous voulez il n'y a pas eu la
participation des administrés et des
politiques locaux il voulait pour gérer
ces problèmes en parfaire le débat sur
la décharge et l'ingénieux parce qu'il
faudrait beaucoup de temps mais
simplement en un mot si vous aviez le
pouvoir de décider les uns les autres
est ce que vous dites oui à l'ouverture
de cette décharge à nonant le pin ou non
mais écoutez 6-7 6-7 décharger
polluantes
si cette décharge met en cause la santé
des riverains des personnes qui sont
autour
mais il faut que l'état de manière
autoritaire la ferme mais moi je ne suis
pas socialiste je n'ai pas eu accès si
vous voulez a donné vie comment vous
avez je n'ai pas d'avis je ne suis pas
expert je sais pas s'il ya pollution
mais si la pollution avérée ce que je
sais c'est que ces droits la
responsabilité chez les de l'état je
dois effectivement la loi et tous ces
établissements classés à hauts risques
soumis à des procédures extrêmement
lourdes d'autorisation d'ouverture c'est
procédures doivent être respectées à
partir du moment où est là et on le voit
bien ça tout arrive devant les tribunaux
en tout cas c'est pas le pouvoir
politique qui peut avoir une idée
ce n'est pas non plus le représentant de
l'état personnes individuelles c'est un
ensemble de dispositifs juridiques qui
existent dans notre pays et aux qualifs
hausse conforme syli adam j'ai éprouvé
il faut pas l'ouvrir mais il va falloir
utiliser ce qui a été fait parce qu'on
ne jette pas non plus des travaux qui
ont été faits il faut l'utiliser
peut-être pour autre chose c'est ici
qu'est une vraie réflexion collective
qui soit menée sur un site de plusieurs
hectares qui correspond à un ras le bol
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait si jamais il n'y
a pas d'autorisation je rappelle qu
ancien ministre ump n'avait pas fait ce
qu'il fallait pour que ce sujet ne soit
pas trois enseignements ne fait
strictement rien là dessus non plus
terminé
en l'état actuel les réflexions jeu - 6
po
il faut fermer ces charmantes aux gens
mais pour l'état actuel de ce que l'on
entend je crois qu'il faut fermer ou
trouver une technologie qui permettent
d'isoler complètement
eh bien on terminera à part ça on avait
encore beaucoup de sujets a évoqué dans
le département de l'orne
on suivra les résultats évidemment sur
nos antennes france bleu france 3 et
dans le journal ouest france les 22 et
prochain la semaine prochaine nouveau
débat consacré aux enjeux dans le
calvados merci chaunu nous avoir
accompagnés
merci aux cinq candidats qui ont
participé à cette émission merci
francisco vient de france bleu et
patrick brion une pauvresse france bon
week-end et à samedi prochain